in diesem video hier habe ich euch
gezeigt wie am karlsruher institut für
technologie daran geforscht wird co2 aus
der luft zu saugen um daraus zu machen
das passiert in einem der vier
kopernikus projekte power tricks die vom
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung gefördert werden
dieses video hier ist quasi der zweite
teil dieser kleinen serie
denn es geht um das kopernikus projekt
synergie die ausgangssituation ist hier
eine ganz ähnliche die stromproduktion
von erneuerbaren energien schwankt
nachts scheint die sonne nicht und
manchmal wird eben einfach kein wind
anders herum gibt es tage an denen wir
mehr sonne und wind bekommen als uns
gerade lief ist wir wissen gar nicht
wohin mit all dem strom
beides ist problematisch denn unser
stromnetz ist darauf ausgelegt dass
immer genauso viel strom produziert wird
wie auch verbraucht wird passiert das
nicht dann kann sich die frequenz des
stromnetzes verändern oder das netz
bricht im schlimmsten fall sogar
komplett zusammen
er ist droht der blackout aber hier
kommt eine spannende idee ins spiel wenn
wir schon nicht die erzeugung des stroms
kontrollieren können wie so versuchen
wir da nicht den verbrauch zu steuern
das klingt im ersten moment vielleicht
total banal ist es aber überhaupt nicht
denn eigentlich was bisher immer genau
andersherum wir haben verbraucht was wir
nun mal verbraucht haben und die
stromerzeugung meist in form von gas
oder kohlekraftwerken musste
entsprechend zu oder abgeschaltet werden
was nun versucht wird ist ein
paradigmenwechsel
wir versuchen unsere nachfrage zu
flexibilisieren
wie wir das hinkriegen könnten und wie
man so ein riesiges projekt umsetzt das
will ich heute herausfinden
herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen video
bei doktor watson unsere idee ist für
flexibilisieren
[Musik]
das heißt dann zu produzieren wenn der
strom so günstig ist runde hat auch zu
steuern
ok ok ok verbrauch anpassen schön und
gut aber heißt das wir müssen alle das
licht ausmachen wenn nachts der wind
aufhört zu gehen
nein private haushalte können auch ihren
teil dazu beitragen aber knapp die
hälfte des stroms in deutschland wird
tatsächlich von der industrie verbraucht
hier liegt ein riesiges bisher
ungenutztes potenzial das projekt
energie hat sich deswegen an geschaut wo
in der industrie am meisten strom
verbraucht wird und wie man diesen
verbrauch steuern kann
wenn man es hier schafft sich an die
stromerzeugung anzupassen dann kann das
stromnetz trotz der schwankenden
einspeisung durch erneuerbare energien
stabilisiert werden und das so hofft man
soll sich am ende für alle lohnen für
die gesellschaft weil unser strom grüner
wird für die netzbetreiber weil die
schwankende produktion aufgefangen wird
und auch für die industrie selber wenn
der strom günstiger eingekauft werden
kann oder ob flexibilität als
dienstleistung verkauft wird
die idee ist eigentlich ganz simpel wenn
viel strom da ist dann kann die
produktion hochgefahren werden und wenn
die sonne gerade nicht scheint oder kein
wind weht dann fährt die produktion
entsprechend herunter das spart co2 und
geld
deswegen arbeiten wissenschaftlerinnen
und wissenschaftler zusammen mit
industrieunternehmen an technologien mit
denen man flexibel mehr oder weniger
strom verbrauchen kann ebenso wie es
gerade nötig ist
aber machen unternehmen das überhaupt
mit ist es nicht viel zu aufwändig den
output der fabrik ständig zu erhöhen
oder zu verringern
je nachdem wie gerade der wind weht das
habe ich mal dennis bauer gefragt der
ist der projektkoordinator von synergie
bisher allerdings war die industrie sehr
stark darauf ausgerichtet immer einen
effizienten betriebspunkt zu fahren das
heißt prozesse wurden kontinuierlich an
einem betriebspunkt betrieben es wurde
nicht da davon abgewichen
allerdings mit diesen schwankenden
strompreisen und eben insbesondere dann
wenn die strompreise sehr günstig sind
kann es für die industrie auch für
sinnvoll sein die sie vermeintlich
ineffizienten betriebszustände gezielt
auszunutzen
das heißt dann zu produzieren denn der
strom sehr günstig ist und der strom ist
natürlich dann besonders günstig wenn
gerade viele erneuerbare energien im
netz sind also der strom besonders grün
ist auf diese weise können unternehmen
geld sparen und etwas für die umwelt tun
weil mehr grüner strom verbraucht wird
und man seltener konventionelle
kraftwerke
dazu schalten muss dazu muss man auch
sagen dass die strompreise für die
industrie viel stärker schwanken als für
uns verbraucher und bei den mengen die
da teilweise verbraucht werden stehen am
ende des monats richtig große summen auf
der stromrechnung
da gibt es zum beispiel trimet das
unternehmen stellt aluminium her und
verbrauch circa 1,6 prozent des gesamten
stroms in deutschland
das muss man sich mal vorstellen das ist
ungefähr so viel wie der stromverbrauch
der stadt essen wo das unternehmen sitzt
mit allen knapp 600.000 einwohnern und
einschließlich aller anderen industrie-
und gewerbebetriebe trimet hat einige
ihrer elektrolyse offen so umgebaut dass
sie für eine kurze zeit überschüssige
leistung aus dem stromnetz aufnehmen
können sie werden also quasi wie eine
batterie aufgeladen
danach kann die elektrische leistung der
öfen für einen ähnlich langen zeitraum
wieder reduziert werden
die virtuelle batterie gibt also wieder
strom an das netz zurück weil weniger
strom verbraucht wird als normalerweise
die energiedichte gespeichert werden
kann entspricht ganz grob 20.000
elektroautos ist also nicht zu
unterschätzen
ein anderes beispiel ist die sogenannte
kryogenen luft erregung die firma linde
erforscht gerade wie man die produktion
von flüssiggasen flexibilisieren kann
hierfür werden circa 300 megawatt
leistung benötigt die man dem stromnetz
als spielraum für lastspitzen zur
verfügung stellen kann
dabei sollen die produkte tanks als
puffer genutzt werden
noch größer ist das potenzial bei der
luft zerlegung vor ort zum beispiel bei
stahlwerken wenn man auch diese
flexibilisiert dann könnte man sogar
noch einmal doppelt so viel erreichen
und das sind nur zwei beispiele gewesen
viele industrien lassen sich
grundsätzlich flexibilisieren zum
beispiel die chemieindustrie die
papierherstellung oder auch das
kunststoff spritzgießen und die wenigen
die nicht flexibilisiert werden können
sind auch kein problem
aber jedes bisschen das wir rausholen
können hilft unserem stromnetz und ist
ein weiterer schritt auf dem weg zur
energiewende
wie groß ist dieser schritt das kann man
über das sogenannte flexibilitätsklausel
erahnen
dieses gibt an wie viel spielraum wie
mit der flexibilisierung der industrie
sowohl nach oben als auch nach unten
erreichen könnten und das sind nach
aktuellen schätzungen des projekts das
äquivalent von bis zu 5
durchschnittlichen braunkohlekraftwerken
okay das klingt ja anderen für sich
alles super vielversprechend aber was
muss denn noch alles passieren um das
auch wirklich zu erreichen
aktuell wird ja in einigen unternehmen
aktiv geforscht aber flexibilisierungen
ist glaube ich für die allermeisten noch
gar kein begriff
erst mal müssen noch viele technologien
erforscht und getestet und installiert
werden die flexibilisierten elektrolyse
öffnen von trimet sind zum beispiel für
einige millionen euro umgebaut worden
und benutzen jetzt eine komplizierte
magnet kompensation die es so vorher
einfach noch gar nicht gab
das ist eine mega coole innovation aber
eben auch eine investition
das ist also ein langer prozess wirklich
mehrere branchen zu flexibilisieren
auch sollte man die soziale seite nicht
außer acht lassen wenn sich dinge im
gewohnten arbeitsumfeld verändern
prozesse anders gefahren werden oder
sogar ganz neue tätigkeiten gibt dann
wird dabei von den leuten eine gewisse
akzeptanz abverlangt es ist wichtig dass
für diese veränderungen verständnis da
ist und dann gibt es da noch die
ökonomische seite
die industrie wird aktuell dafür belohnt
prozesse kontinuierlich zu fahren das
heißt stromverbrauch sieht ungefähr so
aus nämlich immer gleichmäßig damit
flexibilität aber großflächig
bereitgestellt wird und viele
unternehmen die sie bereitstellen
es ist notwendig diesen volatilen
zustand also diese sich ändernde
betriebszustände auch wirklich zu
fördern und die unternehmen da dafür zu
belohnen diese flexibilität nicht nur
anzubieten sondern auch wirklich dann
einzusetzen
konkret bedeutet das dass man einige
gesetze anpassen müsste um nicht mehr
eine konstante sondern eine flexible
stromnachfrage zu belohnen
die meisten unternehmen werden erst dann
mitmachen wenn es sich auch
wirtschaftlich rechnet eine zentrale
rolle spielen dann sogenannte
aggregatoren diese bündeln die
flexibilität mehrerer kleiner
unternehmen und betriebe und bieten
diese als paket an
käufer sind die netzbetreiber die sich
für einzelne unternehmen wahrscheinlich
nicht interessieren würde
denn aktuell gilt leider noch nur wer
viel flexibilität anbietet ist auch
interessant und um mir mal anzuschauen
wie das ganze genau funktioniert bin ich
nach münchen zu einem sogenannten
flexibilitäts vermarkter gefahren
[Musik]
wir hatten eine situation mit dem weg
summer 2018
es war draußen kalt manche hatten
frühnebel aufgrund von dem frühnebel
hatten wir weniger erzeugung aus
solaranlagen und wir mussten da relativ
schnell darauf reagieren die
übertragungsnetzbetreiber hatten am
vormittag hat sind die gesamte
regelenergie aktiviert also das was sie
im notfall machen und sie war
aufgebraucht
und dann kam auch schon um 10 uhr etwa
morgens die anrufe bei uns und wir haben
das einen bildschirm nachverfolgen
können die situation wie kritisch die
war dass das stromnetz wenn wir nicht
eingegriffen hätten gegebener zeit
zusammengebrochen wäre dazu ist es nicht
gekommen weil wir eben die
industrieanlagen steuern konnten
abschalten konnten und so hatten wir die
situation am nachmittag großteils wieder
stabil
für diese abschaltung und generell die
bereitstellung der flexibilität bekommen
die unternehmen geld denn wenn das
stromnetz im dezember 2018
zusammengebrochen wäre dann wäre der
schaden für die
übertragungsnetzbetreiber und auch die
komplette region noch viel größer
gewesen
licht kühlschrank internet und
handyempfang ohne strom geht im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert nicht mehr
viel
eine weitere aufgabe von aggregatoren
ist deshalb eine art versicherung wenn
unternehmen gerade mal nicht flexibel
sein können dann springen aggregatoren
ein und stellen diese flexibilität
ersatzweise von anderen unternehmen zur
verfügung
aktuell lohnt sich das alles aber gerade
für kleine unternehmen noch nicht so
wirklich wie gesagt müsste die
gesetzgebung da noch etwas tun
auch die größte hürde die wir haben ist
dass die politik bei flexibilisierung
hauptsächlich an erzeugung denkt und gar
nicht an industrie lasten und
lastmanagement was wir machen
dabei ist es aber so neue gaskraftwerke
müssen erstmal gebaut werden kostet
investition und genehmigungsprozesse die
industrie lassen die sind schon da
außerdem stehen die industrie lasten in
den verbrauchszentren nicht den direkt
werden nicht auf dem freien feld
irgendwo gebaut wir brauchen kein
netzausbau und die letzte sache wenn wir
die industrie den verbrauch reduzieren
und senken wir ja auch die co2 emission
anders als wenn wir fossile kraftwerke
hoch
in zukunft könnte es sogar einen
marktplatz geben an dem alle
flexibilität handeln können große
industrieunternehmen aber auch kleine
betriebe und sogar haushalte damit so
ein flexibilitäts markt entstehen kann
zumindest sobald der rechtliche rahmen
dafür geschaffen ist testet das projekt
synergie diesen markt schon mal in der
praxis und zwar in augsburg bis 2022
soll hier der erste groß angelegte tests
stattfinden bei dem fünf unternehmen
ihre flexibilität den örtlichen
netzbetreibern zur verfügung stellen
[Musik]
ok erneuerbare energien schwanken aber
das muss kein problem sein wenn die
industrie hilft das netz zu
stabilisieren
dazu braucht es einen digitalisierten
markt auf dem flexibilität angeboten und
nachgefragt werden kann
in einem ersten schritt ist das vor
allem für unternehmen interessant die
einen extrem hohen strombedarf haben
ist der handel mit flexibilität
allerdings erfolgreich dann könnten auch
kleine unternehmen und sogar haushalte
an diesem flex markt teilnehmen
wir bewegen uns mit großen schritten auf
eine nachhaltige flexible und dezentrale
energieversorgung zu und davon
profitieren wir am ende alle habt ihr
ideen was man noch alles flexibel
gestalten könnte schreibt mir gerne
unten in die kommentare und lasst uns
darüber diskutieren
vielen dank einem jan zacharias und die
kollegen von entelios dafür dass wir bei
euch vor ort drehen durften danke auch
an dennis bauer vom fraunhofer institut
für produktionstechnik und
automatisierung und den projektträger
jülich für die unterstützung bei diesem
projekt und vielen dank an das
bundesministerium für bildung und
forschung das die kopernikus projekte
ins leben gerufen hat wenn euch das
video zu e views anschauen wollt von dem
anderen kopernikus projekt dann könnt
ihr gerne da klicken
ansonsten bis nächste woche bleibt wie
immer neugierig cedric